thousands of people have been forced
from their homes by a massive and
fast-moving wildfire near California's
Yosemite National Park 4,000 families
have been ordered to evacuate including
everyone in the town of Mariposa Latimer
duthiers of our streaming network cbsn
is following the developing situation
Platte good morning good morning fire
crews are coming in from all over
California to fight what's being called
the Detweiler fire it started on Sunday
but exploded in size over the last 24
hours
now it's threatening to cut power to
Yosemite National Park the fire raced
down the mountainside in Mariposa
California Tuesday fueled by strong
winds and hot dry conditions hundreds of
firefighters are working around the
clock to battle the flames overnight
video shows them on the front lines
trying to protect the building from the
encroaching wall of fire you can see the
ground still smoking as the crews
scramble to keep up when you add in the
fact that we're in the foothills when
you add in slopes and grades and the
temperatures that we're dealing with the
humidity's that we're dealing with it's
a it's a full-on challenge to the south
emergency crews are facing a new
challenge the fire is threatening power
lines that supply electricity to all of
Yosemite National Park
the massive wildfire burned more than
25,000 acres and prompted mandatory
evacuations 4000 people have been forced
from their homes as California's
governor declared a state of emergency
1500 buildings are still in its path
everybody is scared you'd never think
something like this would happen in your
town temperatures are supposed to cool
down today but windy conditions will
continue to fan the flames keep in mind
emergency crews aren't just fighting the
fires they're also battling steep remote
terrain and that makes the effort that
much harder beyond yeah that wind will
definitely not help them Vlad thank you